so maybe uh we both played Diablo maybe
Diablo was created to see if a druid
your character could defeat Uber Lilith
at the end they didn't know well the
funny thing is Uber Lilith uh her title
is hatred incarnate yeah um and right
now I guess you can ask the Diablo team
but it's almost impossible to defeat
hatred uh in the Eternal realm yeah
you've streamed yourself dominating tier
100 nightmare Dungeons and still I I I
can cruise through tier 100 nightmare
dungeons like a stroll in the park mhm
and still you're defeated by hatred yeah
I can this the sort of I guess maybe the
second hottest boss is duriel durial
can't even scratch the paint so uh I
killed D darel so many times um and
every other boss in the game all all of
them kill them so many times it's easy
um but uh Uber lth otherwise known as
hatred
incarnate especially if you're a druid
and you have no ability to go to be in
vulnerable you there these random death
waves that that come at you
um and I'm pretty you know I'm 52 so my
reflex is not what they used to be but
I'm I have a lifetime in playing video
games uh at one point I was you know
maybe one of the best Quake players in
the world um actually won money for what
I think was the first PID Esports
tournament in the US um we're doing four
person Quake tournaments and
um we came second I was the second best
person on the team and the actual best
person that we we're actually winning we
could have come first except the best
person on the team his computer crashed
halfway through the game um so we we
second but I got money for it and
everything so like basically I got
skills you know I'll be at you know no
no spring spring chicken these days and
um the to be totally Frank it's driving
me crazy trying to beat Lilith as a
druid basically try trying to beat
trying to beat hatred and connate in the
Eternal realm as a druid as a druid and
if you if you if you this is
really vexing let me tell you um I mean
the challenge is part of the fun I I
have seen directly like you're actually
like a world class Incredible video game
player yeah and I think Diablo so you're
just picking up a new game and you're
figuring out its fundamentals you're
also with the Paragon board and the
build are not somebody like me who
perfectly follows whatever they suggest
on the internet you're also an innovator
there yeah which is hilarious to watch
it's like a it's like a mad scientist
just trying to figure out the the
Paragon board and and the build and you
know um is there some interesting
insights there about um if if somebody's
starting as a druid do you have a
device um I would not recommend playing
a druid in the atonal realm um right now
I think the most powerful character in
this in the seasonal realm is the
sorcerer with the lightning balls mhm
the SS have huge balls in um the
seasonal oh yeah that's what they
say so have huge balls um they do uh
huge balls of lightning I'll take your
word for it and it's actually in the
seasonal realm you can you can it's it's
like pretty easy to beat uh U lth with
the because you get these vampiric
powers that amplify your damage and
increase your defense and whatnot so um
really quite easy to defeat hatred
seasonally but to defeat hatred
eternally very difficult um almost
imposs it's
un impossible it seems like this a
metaphor for life you know I like the
idea that Elon Musk because I saw I was
playing Diablo yesterday and I saw 100
level 100 Druid just run by I will never
die and then run back the other way and
it there's just some this metaphor is
kind of hilarious that you Elon Musk is
fighting
hatred restlessly fighting hatred in
this demonic realm yes it's it's
hilarious I mean it's pretty hilarious
really it's exercise and absurdity and
it makes me want to pull my hair out
yeah um he what do you get from video
games in general is there is there for
you for
you personally it's I don't know it's uh
it Cals my mind I mean you sort of
killing the demons in a video game calms
the demons in my
mind yeah if you play a tough video game
you can get into like a state of flow
which is very
enjoyable um and uh but admittedly it
needs to be not too easy not too hard um
kind of in the goldilux zone um and I
guess you generally want to feel like
you're progressing in the game
so um a good video and and there's also
beautiful art um engaging
storylines um and it's a it's like an
amazing puzzle to solve I think and so I
just like solving the puzzle Elden ring
the greatest game of all time I still
haven't played it but you it's Elden
ring is definitely a candid for best
game ever top five for sure I think I've
been scared how hard it is oh how hard I
hear it is so but is beautiful alen ring
is feels like it's designed by an
alien um there's a theme to this
discussion in what way it's it's it's so
unusual it's incredibly creative and the
art is
stunning I recommend playing it on a on
a big resolution P Dynamic R TV even
doesn't need to be a monitor just uh the
art is incredible it's so
beautiful and and it's it's so
unusual
um and each of those top boss battles is
unique like it's like a unique puzzle to
solve each one's different um and the
strategy you use to solve one battle is
different from another battle that said
you said Druid an eternal against Uber
Lilith is the hardest boss battle you've
ever correct that is currently the the
and I've I've played a lot of video
games because my primary recreational
activity yes
um
and
yes beating hatred in the internal realm
yeah is the hardest boss battle
in life and in the video game
man I'm not sure it's possible but it's
I do make progress so then I'm like okay
I'm making progress
maybe if I just tweak that Paragon board
a little
more I can do it could just dodge a few
more waves
M I can do it well the simulation is
created for the purpose of figuring out
if it can be done and you're just a cog
in that simulation in the machine of the
simulation yeah it might
be I I I I I have a feeling that at
least I
think it's doable it's doable yes mhm
well that's the human Spirit right there
to believe yeah I mean it did prompt me
to think about just hate in general
which is
you want to be careful of one of those
things where you wish for something
something that sounds
good but but if you get it it's actually
a dystopian
situation so you know you could sort of
run a sort of uh hypothesis of like if
you wish for World Peace sounds good MH
but how's it
enforced and and at what cost is is what
at what cost Eternal peace it might
actually be worse to have eternal peace
because of what that would entail the
suppression of
everyone it might be the suppression of
progress it might be an oopi society
that never changes mhm one I'm saying is
that there is an
argument
that you you that if that if you wish
for no war you should be careful what
you wish
for because what's required in order for
there to be no
war might be worse than a little war
yeah the things we consider to be flaws
of human civilization might be
unnecessary components for whatever
optimal looks
like